shonda rhimes is one of four covers on
the 50 over 50
inclusive capital issue and it's four
female covers which is super exciting
for forbes
she is the only woman from hollywood to
get a cover and i think that's
important and iconic especially because
she's a black woman in hollywood
and hollywood not only has over the last
few years been reckoning with a metoo
problem in terms of
gender discrimination or sexual
harassment and assault and kind of how
difficult it is for women to really
succeed sometimes
shonda rhymes might be a surprising fit
for the 50 over 50
list because a lot of her biggest hits
came out before
she turned 50 grey's anatomy scandal how
to get away with murder
but uh the reason she's on the list is
really because
at 51 she's entered a new phase in her
career with the netflix deal she made a
few years ago
and with bridgerton being this
international mega hit for netflix
when shonda was at abc she was basically
the queen of the network
to the outside world right she was
commanding thursday night she was
getting the most viewers she
there were a ton of headlines saying how
she was saving broadcast tv
but behind the scenes there was always a
negotiation
by the end she was getting paid a lot
you know 250
000 an episode for grey's anatomy at the
same time
you know she always had to kind of fight
to prove her value to abc and to disney
and that's even after she brought in two
billion dollars
uh to the disney empire around 2017 she
started to realize
i'm one of the best storytellers in
television right now i'm one of the most
valuable show runners why am i fighting
to
to get paid what i deserve or to get the
creative freedom i deserve
and she started to meet with netflix
with ted sarandos
at that point she realized where she
could get paid a ton of money up front
but more than just the money she could
get creative freedom
flexibility she can make the kind of
shows she wanted to make
and she's really embraced that as ever
since um and we saw that with bridgerton
which was the first show of her netflix
deal to come out
and it became within a few weeks uh
netflix's number one show
ever in the first 28 days 82 million
households or 40 percent of netflix's
paying audience
watched the eight episode series uh
bridger tim that smashed previous
viewing records
a second season was buffed within weeks
in april
netflix renewed for seasons three and
four and there's also a spin-off in the
works uh based around her character
queen charlotte
so shonda who is already making 30
million dollars a year to create
exclusive content for the streamer is
expected to receive millions in bonus
pay because of the series success
[Music]
shonda rhimes was the first person to
sign an overall deal with a streaming
service
and that was a really big deal back in
2017 when it happened
netflix she earned the most money in
2021 than
she's earned in her whole career she'll
earn close to 70 million dollars this
year we estimate
close to 40 million of that is coming
from netflix and then she still
obviously is making grey's anatomy in
station 19
and she also gets eight figures in her
share of
grey's anatomy scandal on how to get
away with murder profits
since her television career began in
she's earned more than 350 million
dollars pre-tax making her
one of the biggest show runners uh in
terms of earnings in hollywood history
she knows what she deserves and she's
clear about what she deserves
she's this huge overarching figure and
so it's it's really cool to see that
here's this 51 year old woman in
hollywood and she's still just getting
started and there's so much more
of her career left especially when it
comes to
an industry that really idolizes youth a
lot
she is building the kind of company that
that hollywood needs more of
you know a lot of women um it's
extremely inclusive of
every kind of race and every gender and
and that's just so important um
that you know she's not only putting
people of color in her shows
she's actually building this empire this
company that is inclusive on
on all the rungs of the latter if she
continues
being as successful as she is she will
be the highest paid show runner in
television
and i think it's just a real lesson on
betting on yourself and betting on your
abilities to succeed
you